some people learn the hard way don't
threaten batman with a good time comic
book aficionados know all too well to
keep their eyes extra appeal during a
new superhero movie from marvel to dc
these films often contain an assortment
of easter eggs and hidden references
designed to reward those who have kept
up with the character's comic book roots
sometimes these references are thrown in
just for fun while in other cases
they're designed to hint at greater
machinations at play the batman
certainly has no shortage of easter eggs
right from the very beginning the very
first murder takes place on halloween
night it's hard to hear that without
immediately thinking of one of the best
most popular batman stories to ever
grace the pages of comic book the long
halloween the rest of the film may
deviate from that storyline but the
influences of that story remain clear
there's also the quick line catwoman
gives toward the end of the film where
she mentions heading to bloodhaven which
has great significance to the lore of dc
comics of course not every easter egg
has to deal with batman himself we found
one that seems like it's referencing one
of star robert pattinson's previous
cinematic outings
robert pattinson has an extensive
filmography while most general
moviegoers may know him for his role of
edward in the twilight series he has a
litany of independent projects that
prove he's a master at his craft anyone
who has seen him perform in cosmopolis
high life or the lighthouse was surely
ecstatic when the announcement came that
he would soon take on the role of bruce
wing however there's a little-known
movie patton since starting that's
certainly worth your time especially
seeing how it may have received a shout
out in the batman 2017's good time sees
pattinson play connie nicus a criminal
on the run after a robbery goes sideways
it's an intense thriller from the safety
brothers who would go on to give the
world a more high profile thriller with
the adam sandler starring uncut gems the
film earned rave reviews from critics
and general audiences according to
rotten tomatoes so you should check it
out if you have the chance you can rent
or purchase it on amazon prime video if
you're interested in checking out a
great non-superhero movie that will
still get your blood pumping the movie
also seemed to make an appearance in the
batman early in the film there's an
establishing shot of a market with an
awning reading good times grocery it's
hard not to see that and not immediately
think of pattinson's resume of course it
could just be a coincidence but it's fun
to think matt reeves wanted to include a
lesser-known patent easter egg in a
superhero flick plenty of people may
wonder why director matt reeves would
specifically want to give a shout out to
good time as opposed to any other movie
in pattenson's filmography as it turns
out good time played a significant role
in getting patents in the part to bruce
wayne in the first place in an interview
with esquire reeves mentioned watching
good time and immediately knew pattinson
was his guy he elaborated in the process
of writing the batman i watched good
time and i thought okay he's got an
inner kind of rage that connects with
this character and a dangerousness and i
can feel this desperation and i became
dead set on and being robbed reeves goes
on to mention how he didn't even know at
the time that pattinson would have any
interest in taking on the character but
he so desperately wanted him to be as
bruce wayne as it turns out pattinson
was more than game provided he could do
a really dirty slimy version of the
character as pattinson stated in an
interview with moviemaker at the time
even my agents thought it pretty out of
character to just suddenly get fixated
on batman and i didn't even really know
the status of the project both men got
their wishes as reeves was able to cast
patins in and the actor indeed plays a
dirtier iteration of the caped crusader
in the film he went on to tell premiere
batman lives a criminal life but without
committing crimes i felt like i could
get something out of that anyway i could
only play a superhero if he was really
dirty everything worked out for the best
in the end turns out pattinson had a
good time as batman after all
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]